okay so let me explain to you my sleep
schedule for the bbs oh i want to get it
i was just when i really wanted to go on
okay
okay because my my sleep schedule was
disgusting
um because because at the time a lot of
my friends were online
and a lot of them unfortunately were in
north america right which the best time
to talk to them was
either like probably like really late
for us you know so
you just get used to staying up super
super late so that was fine when i was
in university because it was easy to do
all nighters anyway
but when i was working at the bbc um i
had a nine-to-five job
so i'd i'd need to get up i lived five
minutes away from my workplace
that was a good thing because if if i
didn't my sleep schedule would be even
worse than it already was
so i would stay up till about
um till about four a.m yeah every day
right it's pretty normal
yeah but i would wake up at eight so i
would have i would have like
four i would have four hours of sleep do
my nine to five
monk preparation do my nine to five with
four hours of sleep
be [ __ ] dead for the entire day um
and then go back home at around five six
o'clock
have have a two hour nap and then that
was my sleep schedule
i never had one long sleep it was always
like intermittent
like i would i would have a maximum of
like three to four hours
at a time every night just like space
spaced out by like eight hours
yeah that was my sleep schedule for a
full year jesus i think
being friends with americans especially
in the uk because of how the time zones
work you're like five hours ahead you
end up like you're talking to them
you're having a good time and you're
like
yeah i can talk for an hour extra yeah
it constantly like the hour extra ads
yeah exactly yeah before you know it the
sun's rising and you're like
[ __ ] yeah i i mean
oh yeah of course oh okay yeah like i
was the similar thing because like
as you said like a lot of my like
youtuber friends were in north america
or
not in australia especially so i always
had to adjust to their time zones and
that was usually like three or four a.m
right but the but at least i didn't have
to get up at like
8 a.m i would get up at like maybe 2 p.m
yeah that was
like if i got up if i got up before noon
that was weird for me i'm just like
that's this is this isn't right
i can feel the morning sun i felt the
morning sun before i went to bed
i don't know if you guys did this but i
would like just slowly
deteriorate my sleep schedule so it got
to the point where i was going to bed at
like six
seven a.m yeah yeah and then i would you
know wake up at like
four p.m yeah right um like
i would do the thing where i would
completely [ __ ] it and then i'm like
i'm gonna fix it today and then i fix it
and then i immediately start just
chipping away at it
right it like offsets by an hour then an
hour it turns yeah yeah
yeah two hours and it's three hours
you'll have that one night you and you
i'm sure you've had it where you're just
like
for some reason you stayed up until like
8 a.m yeah and you're like
[ __ ] there's no coming back for some
reason when it's when you stay up to 8
a.m it's easier to keep on that
sleep schedule and keep on a healthy
sleep schedule right yeah it's so
it like i physically like i remember
last year it was
so hard for me to try and fix this like
i would try and stay up i would fail
and then i would try and wake up early
and i would fail so i was just in this
loop for like i remember like two months
i was trying to [ __ ] fix this thing
and i could not do it
and then when i did i had to fly to
america and then come back and it's
immediately fun yeah yeah yeah
like so it was like i couldn't win and i
know this sounds so stupid like just
wake up early connor yeah like
lolita just wake up early just do it but
it's like for some reason when you're a
youtuber and you have no
responsibilities
it's like impossible to fix this just
put an alarm on your phone yeah it takes
so much willpower
to fix your sleep schedule oh yeah
that's it's it's really difficult when
you don't have any responsibilities or a
schedule to stick right or people
relying on you apart from your viewers
like this is probably the first year
that i think almost every day i've
gotten up at like a normal human time
yeah cause i remember when i first moved
here you were still waking up pretty
late oh yeah when i was
like when i was first living here like
at my previous place before rocky moved
with me i was getting up at yeah like
you know maybe like
yeah 12 1 pm yeah and i'm just like yeah
this that's
reasonable time yeah i went to bed like
5 a.m last night so
i got my sleep yeah i think being on
this time zone like americans are always
asleep when i want to like do [ __ ] so
it's i just
go to bed and then they're all awake
yeah it's like i don't feel any pressure
to stay up
here there's like no reason unless i'm
out you know yeah because i remember you
talking before about how you would
record videos at 2am
yeah i'd record because i woke up at
like six i don't want to do anything
when i wake up 6 p.m by the way i'd wake
up at like 6 p.m
in wales right before i moved to japan
because i was i was kind of like
i don't know i was pretty depressed i
was like i hated it yeah i was just like
i just wanted to move to japan
i was just stuck in this shitty bedroom
that i didn't like yeah
my brother's bedroom wasn't even mine i
hated it it was in the attic
i hated this room i hated being in wales
i'm sorry parents i love you but
i know i hate living in wales i hated it
so much i had no friends really
yeah and so i i would just stay up until
like
9 10 a.m yeah and then i would go to bed
yeah wake up at 6 00 p.m
and then i couldn't do anything as well
because everything was closed right so i
just
i was just a perpetual site everything
opens and then closes
while you're literally literally
everything would open and close while i
sleep and then when i wanted to eat
anything like i couldn't
i had to like preemptively go to the
shop to buy things that i think i would
want later
yeah for dinner i think like i had a
similar problem like that in japan but i
think it's because i was relying too
much on the convenience of
the 24 hours yeah the combination yeah
because like i would get up but you know
i'd stay up till maybe like 3 a.m and
i'll be like i'm a bit hungry
everywhere else in the world you're
pretty much [ __ ] like you have to look
in your fridge oh america i mean you
know you could do like delivering stuff
like that but it's no
you know in my case like i would get out
of the house literally walk
20 meters to the 7-11 that was like
across the road from my house
yeah and just grab something and come
back i'm like well yeah of course i'm
going to stay up because
there's no time limit